stocke made you an Avenger the world
needs people like you here's the family
neighborhood spider-man sir please
you've been to space these creatures
destroy in my world we have to stop it
here now
their friends are in trouble what are
you gonna do about it I need a suit
Wow
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
as you just saw we have a new spider-man
far from home TV spot to break down
today specifically one part that is
going to be of pretty significant
importance to spider-man far from home
there was a pretty big spoiler that Tom
Holland dropped not too long ago that
has to do with this TV spot so I'll
break it all down and put the connection
together for you in this video first a
quick reminder about my giveaway at the
450,000 subscriber mark I'll be picking
three winners and each will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection if you want to enter
all you have to do is be subscribed to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so this TV
spot starts off with sort of a pep talk
from Nick Fury to Peter Parker we know
from other TV spots that Peter is
filling very overwhelmed his mentor and
father figure Tony Stark just died
everybody is looking towards him to be
the next Iron Man and now he has to
fight these elementals but he just wants
to be a normal teenager he just wants to
hang out with his friends enjoy his
vacation and date MJ but Nick Fury
basically tells him that after
everything he's been through he is no
longer the friendly neighborhood
spider-man but he's an Avenger now
eventually later on in this TV spot and
in other TV spots and the trailers that
we've seen Peters friends are in danger
and this is probably one of the main
factors that do cause him to step up but
then we have this new scene with
Mysterio where he says these creatures
destroyed my world now by Mysterio
saying this he is saying that these
creatures are not from the main
earth-616 universe now this is something
that Tom Hollands spoiled not too long
ago and everybody was freaking out about
it
Simon snapped his fingers these
creatures came through the
yeah
[Applause]
huh
[Applause]
[Applause]
so Tom says that when Thanos snapped his
fingers these creatures came through a
dimensional rift so they came from
whatever world Mysterio claims that he
came from and this is actually pretty
big evidence that these creatures are
under Mysterio's control even though all
of the trailers and TV spots and
interviews that jake gyllenhaal and Tom
Holland have been doing make it seem
like Mysterio and spider-man are going
to be best friends and that Mysterio is
this good guy I don't think many people
are convinced and I think everybody
pretty much still believes that he is in
fact a villain you all have heard me
mention it many times in my spider-man
far from home videos but Mysterio is a
trickster he's an illusionist and he
wants to be a hero he wants to be the
person that everybody loves but right
now everybody loves spider-man and
everybody is expecting spider-man to be
the next Iron Man but Mysterio wants to
be the next Iron Man he wants to be the
hero that everybody loves so he takes
these elementals that he controls and he
fights them making it seem like he's a
hero who is defeating them in the fact
that this trailer and a spoiler drop
from Tom Hollands say that these
creatures these elementals come from the
other universe that Mysterio comes from
just point to more evidence that
Mysterio is in fact controlling them so
now we know that these creatures
officially come from a different
universe let me know your thoughts on
this do you think that Mysterio is
controlling them in a grand illusion to
make himself seem like a hero or do you
think that they're actually just the
main villains and Mysterio is in fact a
good guy let me know in the comments
down below is Mysterio indeed a villain
or do you think he is a hero and again
another reminder about my giveaway at
four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers I'll be picking three
winners and each will get to choose one
item from the Marvel Legends series
collection to enter all you have to do
is be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain and I will also be starting new
giveaways on Instagram and Twitter soon
if you would like to follow me on social
media as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]